[Musique]
jacques abou chaar et prisonniers en
afghanistan
les dernières images de son reportage de
l'autre côté du rocher des bidonvilles
au soleil vue imprenable sur une ville
pour millionnaires
[Musique]
woody allen se confesse à franz koch il
se trouve très ennuyeux très petits
bourgeois et s'apprêtent à voter
démocrate
[Musique]
bonsoir depuis douze jours déjà un
journaliste manque dans notre rédaction
jacquat bouchard il est en prison
quelque part en afghanistan et nous
espérons tous ici qu'il n'est pas dans
l'une de ces prisons que nous
connaissons bien à kaboul un de ces
infâmes gourbis moyen-âgeux dans
lesquels furent exécutés certains
dignitaires de l'ancien régime
jacques est en prison accusés
d'espionnage alors qu'il allait comme
beaucoup d'autres à la quête de
l'information
nous parlons assez peu souvent de
l'afghanistan non qu'il ne s'y passe
rien on que des pressions nous demande
de nous taire nous en parlons assez peu
parce que kaboul et les zones sous
contrôle de l'armée soviétique et de
l'armée afghane nous sont interdites pas
de visa reste donc pour nous les zones
sous contrôle des moudjahidine
anticommuniste leur accès est certes
dangereux mais pas impraticable puisque
des journalistes des médecins s'y
rendent régulièrement pour vous informer
ou soigner les blessés nous parlons peu
souvent de l'afghanistan mais ces
régions que vous connaissez bien pour
les voir très souvent sur nos écrans ce
sont le centre le wardak l'est la région
de race ni et le nord la vallée du
panjshir ce n'est certes pas le club
méditerranée mais ce n'est pas non plus
verdun en revanche rares sont les
journalistes qui peuvent se rendre dans
les zones occidentales de l'afghanistan
proche de la frontière iranienne qui
nous est également interdite
c'est précisément là bas que jacques à
bouchard et ses deux coéquipiers
georges en scène et jean-louis saporito
se rendait jean-louis saporito et
georges en scène sont en france e libre
et presque sauf jacques est en prison et
un journaliste en prison c'est une
information captive
nous ne saurons donc pas ce soir ce qui
se passe dans ces régions occidentales
de l'afghanistan nous ne saurons pas ce
soir mais nous le saurons demain ou
après demain parce que quelqu'un d'autre
ira
un autre journaliste réussira pas
et lui
[Musique]
oh
ah bon
[Musique]
mauroy
non
ça
l'appel à la prière le nom d'allah se
répercute de vallée en vallée jusqu'à
kaboul jusqu'à moscou de même c'est ce
que disent les combattants de la
résistance afghane
opposés au régime de kaboul alliés de
l'urss y maintient à véritable corps
expéditionnaire dans ce pays soldats
soviétiques et afghans contre les
moudjahidine les combattants de dieu
souvent des guérilleros son pied nu et à
l'armement hétéroclite
on a trouvé un convoi d'armes qui devait
les et ratent donc l'ailé un groupe de
moudjahidine qui sont les johnny thys la
musique nous a proposé de se joindre à
ce convoi d'armes donc qu'il y avait
deux gros camions bleus nous sommes
montés dans les camions à l'arrière la
sueur sur les caisses de munitions et
nous sommes partis à rabat qui est une
ville il ya 48 heures de voiture on
s'arrêtait jules de trois heures pour
dormir puis pour les prix y est en fête
et lahonce a traversé tout le
baloutchistan donc au pakistan on est
arrivé à rabat
et puis on devait partir de trois jours
après sur erat en passant par une piste
juste à côté de la frontière iranienne
et les armes elles assez par l'iran ils
attendaient que d'avoir les
autorisations de l'iran puis alors là on
a été bloquée sous la tente et tous les
jours il nous disait bompard demain on
part demain et en fait on est resté 18
jours là sous la tente un petit peu pas
comme des prisonniers mais un petit peu
reclus parce qu'on ne pouvait pas du
tout se sortent pratiquement pas sortir
de la tente parce qu'il ne fallait pas
que les autres groupe de moudjahidine
parce qu'entre eux
il y a des fois il faillit se méfient
les uns des autres
y a pas de résistance unifiée et tout
et il avait l'air d'être très content
parce que ça va pour eux ça le vélo de
représenter beaucoup de choses bon si je
mens peut armer là c'était un des plus
grands aux convois d'armes qu'ils aient
eu alors dans les sésames chinoises
apparemment pas toutes les armes étaient
chinoises kalachnikov et où il y avait
des doutes et des kalachnikovs y avait
ce qu'ils appellent moi je sais pas bien
ce que c'est des visites couilles à
québec à chacun je crois enfin cédé
sorte de mitrailleuse et canon sans
recul
et puis on attendait on buvait le t on
regarde les temps en temps de
s'entraîner donc à tirer
à côté de nous dans le camp on était on
attendait jusqu'au jouer indiquons pour
aller plus loin il nous faut trois
millions alors là on a eu l'impression à
peu se faire inquiéter
et puis et puis n'était plus très
crédibles en fait dans ces conditions là
on peut pas leur faire confiance vaut
mieux rentrer essayer de faire autre
chose et sa rentrée à quoi tu as dû
mener et on a essayé d'aller à candas
refaire le même sujet en fait dans une
autre ville
les armes le grand souci des différents
mouvements ils ont en face d'eux une
puissante armée moderne l'armée
soviétique chars hélicoptères aviation
la guérilla bénéficie d'une excellente
connaissance du terrain de combattants
courageux mais souvent imprudents
sans véritable formation militaire des
combattants individuels aux réactions
parfois déroutante
pourtant ils réussissent depuis plus de
quatre ans à mettre en échec l'armée
soviétique
cent trente mille hommes cet aspect
désordonnée de la guérilla non
structurées et peut-être l'une des
raisons de certains de ses succès autre
handicap de cette guérilla son manque
d'unité plus d'une vingtaine de
mouvements des mouvements qui se
répartissent le territoire afghan en
fonction des tribus et de leur chef
voilà qui explique la deuxième tentative
de l'équipe d'antenne 2 pour entrer en
territoire afghan
ces avc un autre groupe de moudjahidine
qui s'appelle le mas qui
nous a dit oui bien sûr c'est simple on
peut vous y emmener quand vous voulez
non et on a attendu quatre cinq jours
pour un peu se reposer
et puis un jour nous ont dit bon si vous
voulez on part demain donc
on est partis avec eux et
ça veut dire des très très sûr et là on
devait faire la première nuit on devait
faire la route en voiture
c'est là où l'on est de l'accident et la
deuxième nuit on devait faire la fin de
la route à travers un désert en chameau
à face à on connaîtra jamais le voyage
en chameau
je
en fait une heure et demi après leur
départ de tchaman le reportage prendra
fin l'équipe d'antenne 2 avaient pris
place dans le second véhicule un pick up
sorte de type des bâches et après 15 km
en territoire afghan
c'est l'embuscade armes automatiques
balles traçantes tir de face et de côté
il est 22h15 la première jeep sera
touchée au rpg les occupants auront eu
le temps de sauter à terre avant ils
sont indemnes
le deuxième véhicule stoppé durant
quelques secondes repart en trombe avant
de se renverser
jean-louis saporito a déjà sauté georges
en scène est éjecté ainsi
vraisemblablement que jacques à bouchard
à ce moment là les trois membres de
l'équipe d'antenne 2 sont séparés fuyant
vers les dunes
chacun essaie de se mettre à l'abri des
tirs jacquat bouchard blessé à l'épaule
ne pourra s'enfuir
il s'est réfugié derrière une dune au
petit jour ils se rendent à une unité
blindée soviétique qui patrouille dans
le secteur
il sait sur un char jacquat bouchard est
exhibée à la population de spin boldak
une garnison de l'armée afghane
mardi la rédaction d'antenne 2 apprend
l'embuscade un avion spécial part
chercher les blessés
avec également une équipe chargée
d'enquêter sur les circonstances de la
disparition de jacques à bouchard une
enquête qui nous mènera tout d'abord au
siège du mouvement miles ml avec qui
jacques à bouchard tante et sa
pénétration en afghanistan et
moudjahidine eux-mêmes mener une enquête
il avait nommé un ancien juge au
tribunal de kaboul passer à la
résistance pour interroger les
combattants qui se trouvait avec
l'équipe d'antenne 2 je suis sûr que
c'est nous qui étions attendus
nous avons envoyé une moto et une
voiture en éclaireur pour savoir si la
route est libre
elles sont revenus sans problème et vie
moi j'ai remarqué quelque chose
quelques centaines de mètres après notre
départ j'ai vu une fusée verte dans le
ciel je croyais que c'était un mariage
maintenant je sais que c'était un
traître qui signalait notre départ après
l'arrestation le matin dans le bazar de
spin boldak trois chars soviétiques sont
rentrés dans la ville monsieur jacques
était sur le 2ème chars étaient attachés
comme ça les bras et les jambes
il y avait devant les chars un
responsable politique de la propagande
ils disaient nous venons d'arrêter un
agent étranger notre pays est attaqué
par les chinois les américains et les
français
la guerre n'est pas en train de gants
des soldats russes le menacer avec leurs
mitraillettes en disant tu es venu faire
la guerre et lui disais non je suis venu
faire des photos comment se fait-il
une unité ainsi de combattants afghans
soient tombés dans une embuscade aussi
facilement à quelques kilomètres
seulement à l'intérieur du territoire
afghan
mais c'est bien sûr si vous savez corps
maintenant l'heure les soldats suivi des
attaques dans toutes les provinces
d'afghanistan spécialement ils ont
continué l'activité dans le province
kandahar il bombardait partout à l'avion
allait cocktail blindés et avec la
viande de chasse et même à la tempe
il fait beaucoup d action des activités
de l'embuscade par tous ceux normalement
on sa fin est ce qu'il y à des espions
parmi vous savez monsieur que nous
sommes dans l'état de guerre c'est le
poil l'autre le frontier du chaman c'est
dans un journée vous savez que
maintenant il ya un bombardement dans la
ville de kandahar
descente 1 réfugié vient du côté
afghanistan ici dans ce 100e réfugiés
peut-être qu'il y ait quelques quelques
uns des membres de kg b qui donne
l'information encore procureur ils ont
eu des appareils de telegraaf des choses
qui présente copala un groupe qui vient
hélas la décision de rentrer à
l'intérieur d'afghanistan ça c'est
normal
souleymane gallieni responsable du masi
melly chef religieux politiques et
militaires son mouvement au contrôle
théoriquement une partie de la ville de
kandahar et la campagne environnante
l'embuscade tendue par l'armée
soviétique
si près de la frontière avec le pakistan
tu est la preuve de la volonté de kaboul
et de moscou de lancer prochainement une
nouvelle offensive
son but fermez hermétiquement les
frontières de l'afghanistan et empêcher
les trois millions de réfugiés afghans
qui se trouve au pakistan de grossir les
rangs de la guérilla
par ailleurs le piège tendu à l'équipe
d'antenne 2 alors qu'elle se trouvait
avec l'une des unités qu'il commande et
la détention de jacques à bouchard
serait pour kaboul
un exemple pour dissuader les
journalistes d'entrer en afghanistan et
les empêcher de raconter la vérité un
défi à la liberté d'informer
[Musique]